Ist das noch unser Fussball?
Wenn eine WM in der Wüste stattfindet,
in einem schwerreichen Land mit Menschenrechtsproblemen,
und dem weltweit höchsten CO2-Aussstoss pro Kopf?
Seit 2010 ist klar:
Das ist die heutige Fussball-Realität.
Wie konnte es so weit kommen?
Wie hat Katar das geschafft?
Zu diesen Fragen haben wir
in den letzten Monaten intensiv recherchiert.
Wir, das sind Yacine, Fussball-Liebhaber
und Moderator bei RTS,
ich Jenny, Journalistin und Moderatorin bei SRF.
Und unser Produzent Christoph, Journalist bei SRF.
Unterstützt wurden wir von einem nationalen
Recherche-Team von SRF, RTS und RSI.
Zusammen sind wir diesen Fragen
auf den Grund gegangen.
TRILLERPFEIFE
MUSIK UND STIMMENGEWIRR
Yacine, das ist noch Fussball
in seiner Reinform.
Noch total unkommerziell.
Ja, gut. Aber es geht
um die Stimmung, um die Euphorie.
Das heisst: Du schaust die WM?
Du schaust diese Spiele?
Wieso?
Ich glaube nicht.
Mich stört neben der Kritik vor allem,
dass die ganze Atmosphäre flöten geht.
Die WM ist dieses Jahr in Katar.
Wie findest du das?
Sehr cool.
Neu, es ist im November.
Ich finde es nicht sehr passend.
In diesem Land werden die Frauen
quasi misshandelt.
Ich werde schauen.
Ich finde WM und Fussball spannend.
Ich werde nicht viel schauen.
Ich weigere mich ein wenig.
Die Spiele schaue ich natürlich.
Es ist nicht okay.
Es ist nun mal so und
wir schauen das auch im Winter.
Also man ist relativ skeptisch und
kritisch, was diese WM angeht.
Das ist genau das Interessante:
Katar hat keine Fussballtradition.
Aber sie setzen voll und ganz auf den Sport
und machen ihn zum Teil ihrer Identität.
Wie holt sich ein Wüstenstaat
ohne Fussballtradition eine WM?
Das wollen wir in 4 Schritten aufzeigen.
Schritt 1 lautet:
Relevant werden in der Sportwelt.
Dafür hat Katar in den letzten 30 Jahren
eine regelrechte Sportoffensive lanciert.
Angefangen mit dem Tennisturnier in Doha 1993.
Seither jagt ein Sport-Event den nächsten,
und sie werden grösser und grösser.
Mit seinem Geld stampft Katar
die passende Infrastruktur aus dem Boden.
Es gibt Weltmeisterschaften im Handball, Rad,
Turnen oder in der Leichtathletik.
Insgesamt finden in Katar 10 verschiedene WMs statt.
Und nun das Nonplusultra: Die Fussball-WM.
Doch darüber sprechen will niemand.
Wir haben mehrere Fussballer angefragt,
die in Katar gespielt haben — erfolglos.
Ich finde es recht absurd und befremdlich,
dass ein Land wie Katar ohne grosse Sporttradition
plötzlich so einen krassen Fokus auf den Sport legt.
Ich will herausfinden,
welche Motivation dahintersteckt.
Wir fahren nach Bern.
An der dortigen Universität
forscht Laura Rowitz zur Golfregion,
insbesondere zu Katar.
Sport bietet die Gelegenheit für Katar, sich ein
positives, fortschrittliches und modernes Image zu geben.
Oder: Es spielt in Katars
nationaler Erzählung sehr gut rein:
Einen eigenen Entwicklungsweg zu gehen,
sehr stark Visionen zu haben,
einem gewissen Fortschritt zu folgen.
Und Sport bietet die Möglichkeit,
genau diese Erzählung zu stärken
und nach aussen zu verkaufen.
Ist es nicht absurd,
wenn man aus dem Nichts probiert,
eine Identität zu erschaffen, die nichts
mit der eigenen Geschichte zu tun hat?
Also es ist nicht so, dass Katar
keine eigenen Sporttraditionen hätte.
Es gibt verschiedene aus der
Tradition entlehnte Sportarten.
Es gibt die Falknerei,
es gibt Segeln,
Reiten auf Kamelen, auf Pferden.
Das sind eben alles Sachen,
die folkloristisch neu belebt wurden.
Aber Fussball
gehört definitiv nicht dazu.
Katar, ein kleiner Wüstenstaat am Persischen Golf.
Nur gerade ein Viertel so gross wie die Schweiz.
Eingequetscht zwischen zwei Grossmächten:
Saudi-Arabien und Iran.
Von ihnen wird Katar immer wieder unter Druck gesetzt.
Auch deshalb ist internationale Aufmerksamkeit
für die Kataris ein wichtiges Gut.
Lange stand Katar unter britischer Herrschaft.
Erst seit 1971 ist das Land unabhängig.
Seither stellt es sich die Frage:
Wer wollen wir eigentlich sein?
Das katarische Gesetz beruht auf der Scharia,
also dem, was im Koran steht.
Er ist der starke Mann im Land:
Emir Tamim bin Hamad Al Thani,
Alleinherrscher über die knapp 3 Millionen Einwohner.
Von denen sind aber nur die wenigsten Kataris.
Fast 90% sind Arbeitsmigranten,
also Bauarbeiter, Hausangestellte usw.
Ihre Rechte sind eingeschränkt.
Das gleiche gilt für Frauen, sie sind in
der Öffentlichkeit deshalb fast unsichtbar.
Die wichtigsten Einnahmequellen des Landes:
Erdöl und vor allem Erdgas.
Sie machen die Hälfte des Bruttoinlandprodukts aus.
Und genau da kommt das zweite Motiv
für die katarische Sportoffensive ins Spiel.
Katar ist dafür bekannt,
dass sie enorme Erdgasressourcen haben.
Aber diese Ressourcen sind endlich.
Da kommt die Frage nach
einer Diversifizierung der Wirtschaft,
nach einer Neuausrichtung
der Wirtschaft auf.
Katar versucht wie viele
andere Staaten in der Region,
stärker in den Tourismus zu investieren,
in das Transportwesen,
in den Bausektor und so weiter.
Es geht also im Endeffekt doch
auch ums Geschäft und ums Geld.
Es ist eigentlich ein Versuch,
diese Identität
auch mit einer zukünftigen
Einnahmequelle zu verbinden?
Ja, definitiv.
Dass Fussball auch ein Geschäft ist,
dass sich bei Fussball Politik
und Geschäft vermischen,
sehen wir auch in Europa.
Dazu brauchen wir nicht so weit zu gucken.
Das sieht man schon lange.
Und bei Katar ist es eben so,
dass man versucht, Katar als
Wirtschaftsstandort attraktiv zu machen.
Man möchte internationale
Investoren anziehen,
man konkurriert mit den anderen
Golfstaaten um internationale Märkte.
In dieser Rivalität ist es wichtig,
sich eine eigene Identität,
ein eigenes Image aufzubauen.
MUSIK UND STIMMENGEWIRR
ANFEUERUNG AUS DEM PUBLIKUM
UNDEUTLICHE STIMME AUS DEM LAUTSPRECHER
Jetzt macht es etwas mehr Sinn,
warum Katar Austragungsort der
Fussballweltmeisterschaft sein möchte.
Ja, das ist komisch.
Schritt 2 auf dem Weg zur WM:
Man braucht einen kooperativen Partner.
Die Fifa, ein gemeinnütziger Verein,
gegründet 1904 von ein paar
wenigen europäischen Ländern.
Bald zieht der Hauptsitz
an den Zürichberg.
Lang funktioniert die Fifa wie ein Kleinunternehmen
mit wenigen Angestellten.
Zum echten Weltverband wird
die Fifa erst ab den 70er-Jahren.
Der Fussball
wird weltweit vereinheitlicht.
Sepp Blatter reist als ‘Fussball-Entwicklungshelfer’
in mehrere afrikanische Länder.
Die Fifa wächst:
Mehr Mitglieder, mehr Geld.
Die Haupt-Einnahmequelle:
die Männer-WM.
Die Einnahmen generiert sie durch den
weltweiten Verkauf der Fernsehrechte.
Aus der kleinen Fifa ist der grösste
Sportverband der Welt geworden.
Heute besteht die Fifa aus
gut 200 Mitgliedsverbänden,
aufgeteilt in 6 Kontinentalverbände.
Diese stellen je nach Grösse
unterschiedlich viele Mitglieder im Fifa-Rat,
heute das wichtigste Gremium der Fifa.
Wer im Weltfussball mitbestimmen will,
muss hier Einfluss nehmen.
Bis 2016 hiess dieses Gremium noch
Fifa-Exekutivkomitee und war kleiner.
24 Männer, die die wichtigsten Entscheidungen
im Weltfussball gefällt haben,
unter anderem den Austragungsort der WM.
Der innerste Zirkel der Macht also.
Damit man versteht,
wie dieses Gremium funktioniert hat,
muss man sich den Mann anschauen,
der es 17 Jahre lang als Präsident geprägt hat.
Wir machen uns auf eine Spurensuche,
und zwar ins Wallis.
In den Kanton, wo die letzten
beiden Fifa-Präsidenten herkommen.
Zusammen mit
RTS-Journalist Ludovic Rocchi.
Der Fifa-Kenner hat über Blatter und
Infantino einen Dokumentarfilm produziert.
Wir fahren bis zuhinterst ins Wallis:
Nach Ulrichen,
dem Heimatort von Sepp Blatter.
Blatters Vorfahren haben hier gelebt,
er selbst nie.
Und doch gibt es hier einen ‘Blatter-Ort’.
Direkt am Bahnhof,
auf der anderen Seite der Rohne.
Im Archiv finden wir die Bilder von damals.
Vom "Sepp-Blatter-Turnier" in Ulrichen.
Es zeigt, wie Blatters
Fussball-Kosmos funktioniert:
Sepp, umgeben von der nationalen
und internationalen Fussball-Prominenz.
Teils eingeflogen mit
Helikoptern in SEIN Oberwallis.
Es ist doch etwas Schönes,
wenn man die gewisse Popularität hier spürt.
Die kommt aus dem Herzen und ist nicht gespielt.
Und das tut gut.
KUHGLOCKE
Blatters heile Fussball-Welt,
mit ihm als König.
2015 hat das letzte Turnier stattgefunden.
Vom einstigen Glamour
ist heute nicht mehr viel übrig.
Sepp Blatter, ein Mann,
der die Leute gerne nahe bei sich hat,
manchmal ein bisschen zu nahe.
Besonders sein Verhältnis
zu Afrika ist umstritten.
Und zu Mohammed Bin-Hammam,
einem langjährigen Fifa-Offiziellen.
Er unterstützt Blatter 1998 bei der Wahl
zum Fifa-Präsidenten.
Seine Wahl ist eine Überraschung.
Aussenseiter Blatter wird Nachfolger
von Joao Havelange aus Brasilien.
Sofort gibt es Gerüchte von gekauften Stimmen,
von Couverts mit Geld.
Was war in diesen Couverts, die Sie
im Vorfeld verteilt haben, Herr Blatter?
Das ist alles zusammen ein grosser Mist.
Corinne, wir nehmen den anderen Lift.
Warum?
Was haben Sie der "Herald Tribune" erklärt?
Warum hat man Sie so zitiert?
Beweise für
einen Stimmenkauf gibt es nie.
Aber grosszügige Zuwendungen
an afrikanische Fussball-Funktionäre.
Blatter ist jetzt an der Spitze des
mächtigsten Sportverbands der Welt.
Gegen aussen gibt er sich aber
weiterhin als bescheidener Bergler.
Als Arbeiterkind, katholisch aufgewachsen
in einfachsten Verhältnissen.
Hier oben im ersten Stock
hat mein Grosspapa gewohnt,
die ganze Familie.
Es gab kein Badezimmer,
Wasser nur in der Küche.
Als Fussballer schafft er es immerhin
in die 1. Liga.
Karriere macht er aber vor allem
abseits des Rasens.
Er studiert Wirtschaft und Politik,
wird Oberst im Militär
und steigt ins Sportbusiness ein.
Dreimal heiratet er,
dreimal lässt er sich wieder scheiden.
Ich würde sagen:
Meine Verlobte ist die Fifa, ja.
Und seine Verlobte macht er als
Präsident zu dem, was sie heute ist:
Ein Milliarden-Unternehmen.
SPANNUNGSGELADENE MUSIK
Zurück in Ulrichen.
Irgendwie passt dieses ausgestorbene Bergdorf
nicht zu diesem Milliarden-Unternehmen.
Die Fernsehrechte: Dieses Element
bringt die dubiosen Geldflüsse
bei der Fifa so richtig ins Rollen.
Das zeigt der sogenannte
,ISL-Skandal‘ 2010.
Die ISL: eine Firma mit Sitz in Zug.
Sie hat für die Fifa jahrelang
die Fernsehrechte verkauft.
Ein Riesengeschäft,
bei dem Fifa-Offizielle nebenbei
Millionen
an Schmiergeldern kassiert haben.
Aufgedeckt wird das im Jahr 2010,
also kurz vor der WM-Vergabe
nach Katar.
Mittendrin: zwei Mitglieder
des Fifa-Exekutivkomitees,
die wir uns merken müssen:
Nicolás Leoz aus Paraguay
und Ricardo Teixeira aus Brasilien.
Und Blatter wusste davon.
Der britische Journalist
Andrew Jennings
konfrontierte Teixeira
und Leoz mit den Vorwürfen.
MUSIK UND STIMMENGEWIRR
Wir haben hier Katar,
das die WM unbedingt will
und hier die Fifa mit korrupten Tendenzen.
Eigentlich ‘the perfect match’, oder?
Stimmt.
Es waren nur 22, nicht 24,
denn zwei Herren sind schon vorher rausgefault.
Jetzt kommt also
der dritte und entscheidende Schritt:
Die Wahl gewinnen.
Das heisst das Fifa-Exekutivkomitee
von der eigenen Kandidatur überzeugen.
Und das um jeden Preis.
Eine Weltmeisterschaft
kann man nicht kaufen!
Im Oktober 2010, wenige Wochen
vor der WM-Vergabe, wird klar:
Mitglieder vom Fifa-Exekutivkomitee
sind käuflich.
Die britische Zeitung "Sunday Times"
stellt zwei von ihnen eine Falle.
Die Zeitung bietet Geld an,
damit sie für die USA
als WM-Austragungsland stimmen.
Und filmt alles verdeckt.
MUSIK
Reynald Temarii aus Tahiti
verlangt für seine Stimme
Geld für eine Fussballakademie.
Amos Adamu aus Nigeria will dafür
Fussballplätze in seinem Heimatland.
Die beiden 'schlechten Spieler'
werden gesperrt.
Das mächtige Exekutivkomitee schrumpft
kurz vor der WM-Vergabe auf 22 Mitglieder.
Die Weltmeisterschaft wird nicht gekauft.
Oder eben doch?
Der 2. Dezember 2010 in Zürich.
Der Tag der Wahl.
Die Vergabe der WM 2022.
Es gibt 5 Kandidaten:
Katar, USA,
Südkorea, Australien, Japan.
Klarer Favorit: die USA.
Im 4. Wahlgang bleiben noch die USA und Katar übrig.
Und dann ...
Katar! Das ist natürlich eine Riesen-Überraschung!
Katar gewinnt mit 14 zu 8 Stimmen.
Was da noch niemand ahnt:
Es waren offenbar Bestechungsgelder im Spiel.
Und zwar bei den 3 Stimmen von
Ricardo Teixeira, Nicolás Leoz und Julio Grondona.
Teixeira und Leoz kennen wir bereits
vom ISL-Skandal.
Obwohl Blatter wusste, dass sie
korrupt waren, durften sie abstimmen.
Dass sie sich auch für die
Katar-Stimmen offenbar zahlen liessen,
kommt 7 Jahre später raus.
Burzaco.
Ein argentinischer
Fernsehrechte-Händler
erzählt vor dem amerikanischen Gericht
im Detail von den Bestechungsgeldern,
die die drei erhalten hätten.
Wahrgenommen wird das
damals aber fast nirgends.
Für zwei hat das keine Konsequenzen.
Grondona und Leoz
sterben nämlich in diesem Zeitraum.
Anders bei Teixeira.
Er wird von der
Fifa-Ethikkommission lebenslang
für alle Fussballaktivitäten gesperrt
und zu einer Million Franken
Busse verurteilt.
Unter anderem gestützt
auf die Aussage des Kronzeugen.
Die Fifa-Ethikkommission erklärt somit die
Aussage zur Katar-Korruption als glaubwürdig.
Grondona, Teixeira, Leoz.
Die 3 Stimmen sind entscheidend.
Wäre die Abstimmung 11:11 ausgegangen,
wäre der Stichentscheid
beim Fifa-Präsidenten gelegen,
also bei Sepp Blatter.
Und er sagt, er
habe die USA unterstützt.
Eine WM unter Verdacht.
Was sagt die Fifa dazu?
- Hallo, dürfen wir reinkommen?
- Ja, klar.
Hansjürg Zumstein ist der Leiter
unserer Recherche-Gruppe.
Er hat versucht, von Gianni Infantino
persönlich eine Antwort zu bekommen.
Monatelang ist nichts passiert.
Ich habe mehrmals um eine Antwort gebeten.
Ich habe zwei eingeschriebene Briefe
geschickt mit einem Ultimatum,
weil wir diese Antwort ja geben wollten.
Und endlich, nach 4 Monaten
kam eine Antwort.
Es waren im Prinzip zwei Sätze,
die sie zu dieser Frage geschickt haben.
In denen sagen sie:
Es stimmt alles nicht.
Es ist alles ganz falsch.
Sie schreiben: In der Entscheidung
der Fifa-Ethikkommission
sei nie von Bestechungsgeld im
Zusammenhang mit Katar die Rede.
Das ist falsch,
es steht explizit drin.
Hansjürg spricht vom Urteil
des Fifa-Ethikkomitees
gegen Teixeira aus dem Jahr 2019.
Darin sind die
Bestechungsgelder explizit erwähnt.
SPANNUNGSGELADENE MUSIK
Die Fifa-Antwort ist also falsch.
Und auch in einem anderen Punkt
ist die Stellungnahme nicht korrekt.
Gianni Infantino schreibt, es habe darüber
eine detaillierte Untersuchung gegeben,
den sogenannten ‘Garcia-Report’.
Und dieser habe gezeigt, dass es keine
Bestechung rund um Katar gegeben hat.
Zum Garcia-Report muss man sagen:
Der wurde 2014 fertig,
nicht 2017, wie sie hier suggerieren.
Dann wurde er publiziert.
Wie erklärst du dir
diese Reaktion der Fifa?
Ich denke, die haben das Gefühl:
Uns ist egal, was das Schweizer Fernsehen
rund um diese Geschichte publiziert.
Katar hat sein Ziel erreicht,
Der Stadienbau beginnt.
Heute weiss man aber auch:
Nicht nur Katar hat damals
mit Bestechungsgeldern hantiert,
sondern auch andere Bewerber für die WM.
Zum Beispiel Australien.
Ich habe jetzt ein Gespräch mit Bonita Mersiades.
Sie ist eine Whistleblowerin aus Australien
und gehörte ursprünglich zum
australischen Bewerbungskomitee.
Sie hat dieses Buch hier geschrieben:
‘Whatever it takes’.
Darin beschreibt sie Schritt für Schritt,
wie auch Australien versucht hat,
die WM zu kaufen.
Ja, das war verdammt spannend.
Alle reden die ganze Zeit über
Korruption in Verbindung mit Katar
und stellen es dar, als wäre es
ein absolut spezieller Einzelfall.
Während Bonita Mersiades bestätigt,
dass dieses Problem schon seit Jahren,
seit Jahrzehnten besteht.
Sie ist sogar dankbar dafür, dass nun endlich
die Aufmerksamkeit darauf gelenkt wird.
Wie korrupt der innerste Zirkel der Fifa damals war,
weiss man heute besser.
Verzichtet nach Korruptionsvorwürfen
auf eine erneute Wiederwahl.
Auf diesen Papieren sind die 24 Männer
des damaligen Exekutiv-Komitees aufgelistet.
79 Millionen US-Dollar Strafe.
Das Krasse: Von den
24 Männern sind mittlerweile 18
entweder der Korruption überführt
oder wegen dubiosen Geschäften gesperrt.
MUSIK
Ich warte hier auf Sylvia Schenk,
Korruptionsexpertin aus Deutschland.
Ich möchte von ihr wissen,
welche strukturellen Voraussetzungen
bei der Fifa dazu geführt haben,
dass Korruption dort begünstigt wurde.
Und auch, ob sich mittlerweile
etwas geändert hat.
Punktlandung, der ist es, oder?
Frau Schenk, hallo!
- Freut mich sehr, ich bin Jennifer Bosshard.
- Schenk, freut mich.
Silvia Schenk kämpft seit Jahren gegen Korruption
und für einen sauberen Sport.
Wichtig dabei ist Compliance,
also wie regelkonform und ethisch korrekt
sich Unternehmen und Organisationen verhalten.
Bonita Mersiades hat gesagt:
Es gab damals, 2010,
keine Alternative zur Korruption.
Ist das heute anders?
Das kann ich nicht 100 % sagen,
aber es sind seitdem recht viele
Veränderungen eingeführt worden.
Es entscheidet nicht
mehr das Exekutivkomitee,
das inzwischen bei der Fifa Council heisst.
Sondern es entscheidet der Kongress.
Das heisst, es entscheidet eine
viel grössere Personengruppe.
Da wird es schon schwieriger,
diese zu beeinflussen, durch was auch immer.
Und es wurden inzwischen ganz andere
Compliance-Anforderungen aufgestellt.
Also insofern ist es zumindest sehr,
sehr erschwert worden.
100 Prozent kann man nirgends,
auch nicht beim SRF, Korruption ausschliessen.
Gehen wir zurück zum Jahr 2010:
Was hat damals die Korruption begünstigt?
Welche Struktur?
Bei der Fifa gab es bis zu den
beiden Reformprozessen 2011/2012
und dann nochmal nach 2015/2016
erstens sehr lange Amtszeiten.
Blatter sprach ja auch
immer von der ‘Fussballfamilie’.
Man kannte sich,
war miteinander befreundet.
Interessenkonflikte kannte man nicht.
Man half sich untereinander.
Es fehlte auch an Diversität
und vor allen Dingen:
Es fehlten die Frauen.
Es fehlte auch der Beitritt von neuen Leuten,
die dumme Fragen gestellt hätten.
Denn dumme Fragen
wirbeln ganz schnell etwas auf
und man kann nicht mehr
so handeln wie vorher.
Die Compliance, die Sie angesprochen haben,
wurde 2014/2015 eingeführt.
Was hat sich
konkret verändert seither?
Es hat sich deutlich etwas
in der Compliance gewandelt.
Auch wenn das manche Journalisten anders sehen,
hat sich aus meiner Einschätzung
die Frage der Einzelmacht
des Präsidenten gewandelt.
Blatter hat sehr viel mehr Dinge
einfach durchgezogen.
Bei Infantino sehen wir ja,
was alles bisher nicht so geklappt hat:
Zweijahresrhythmus für die
Weltmeisterschaft oder anderes.
Er muss sehr viel mehr
ausbalancieren.
Die Machtverhältnisse haben sich
etwas mehr demokratisiert.
Der öffentliche Druck, die öffentliche
Beobachtung sind stärker geworden.
- Das hilft der Fifa.
- Was könnte sich denn noch verändern?
Was müsste nach Ihrem Wunsch
noch angepasst werden,
damit man wieder mit einem guten Gefühl
Fussball schauen kann,
ohne sich um Korruption zu sorgen?
Das Problem ist:
Sie müssen die ganze Welt ändern.
Ein Journalist fragte mal: Wann
ist der Fussball und die Fifa sauber?
Ich sagte: Wenn die Welt sauber ist.
An dem Fifa-Kongress
haben Sie 211 nationale Verbände.
Ganz viele Länder in der Welt haben mit
Alltagskorruption, mit Korruption im
gesellschaftlichen Leben,
in der Politik und so weiter zu tun.
Wer wird denn in
einem hochkorrupten Land
Präsident vom Fussball- oder vom
Schwimm- oder vom Leichtathletikverband?
Eine Person, die sich in einem
korrupten Umfeld durchsetzen kann.
Es gibt in jedem Land integre Personen,
gar keine Frage.
Die sitzen in vielen Ländern
allerdings eher im Gefängnis,
als an der Spitze eines
nationalen Sportverbandes.
MUSIK UND STIMMENGEWIRR
Bei der Fifa hat man reagiert
und Anpassungen vorgenommen.
Man kann davon ausgehen,
dass eine Abstimmung wie im 2010
heute so wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr möglich wäre.
Es wurde viel Kritik laut
rund um diese WM in Katar.
Was hast du davon mitbekommen?
Einiges. Den Aufbau
der gesamten WM in Katar.
Ich habe mitbekommen, dass es
beim Stadionbau auch Tote gegeben hat.
In Katar ist es sehr, sehr heiss.
Die Arbeiter mussten
einfach durcharbeiten.
Es ist ein Witz, dass man das
an solchen Orten macht.
Für mich ist es fragwürdig,
ob das wirklich sinnig ist.
Man hat relativ schnell
die WM verschoben,
vom Sommer in den Winter,
wegen dem Klima.
Aber bis zum Turnierstart musste dann
doch noch einiges mehr passieren.
Der letzte Schritt auf dem Weg zur WM
ist der vielleicht schwierigste.
Die Kritik an dieser WM ist riesig:
verunglückte Arbeiter,
ökologisch eine Katastrophe und so weiter.
Jetzt geht es darum,
die Kritik abzuwehren
und sich so gut wie
möglich darzustellen.
Damit das gelingt,
lanciert Katar eine PR-Strategie.
Unter anderem
mittels einer Influencer-Agentur.
Es werden prominente Botschafter eingesetzt.
Wie Yaya Toure, Lothar Matthäus
oder David Beckham.
Für ihre Auftritte
werden sie natürlich bezahlt.
Und dann tritt er auf den Plan:
Gianni Infantino, der Katar-Botschafter.
Niemand verteidigt die WM so sehr wie er.
Und niemand versteht sich so gut
mit den Mächtigen der Welt.
Obwohl er selber
früher der Kleinste war.
Er war ein kleiner ‘Piccolino’.
Ein kleiner, aber
liebenswerter Verwöhnter.
Seine Eltern kommen in den 60er-Jahren als
italienische Gastarbeiter ins Wallis nach Brig.
der Vater Hilfsarbeiter,
die Mutter Kioskverkäuferin.
Der kleine Gianni liest die "Gazzetta"
und träumt vom Fussball.
Er studiert Jus,
wird Uefa-Generalsekretär.
Und 2016 Fifa-Präsident.
Der ‘Piccolino’ ganz gross.
Die WM in Katar wird
zu seinem Prestigeprojekt.
Im Januar 2022 zieht er selbst
vorübergehend nach Doha.
Eins, zwei, drei ...
ALLE LAUT: KATAR
Ein Katar-begeisterter Fifa-Präsident.
Mit Fifa-Kenner Ludovic Rocchi
gehen wir auch nach Brig.
Dorthin, wo Infantino aufgewachsen ist.
Infantino wirbt für diese WM,
wo es nur geht.
Er betont das Potenzial
für die ganze Golfregion.
Ein Versprechen ist, dass die WM in Katar
‘vollständig klimaneutral’ sein soll.
Dank verringerten Emissionen,
energieeffizienten Stadien
und kurzen Transportwegen.
Unvermeidbare Emissionen
sollen kompensiert werden.
Die Fifa kann nicht genug betonen,
wie viel sie fürs Klima tut.
In ihrem Klimareport rechnet sie vor,
wie hoch der CO2-Ausstoss ist.
Doch eigenartigerweise wird nur eines
der 8 Stadien wirklich berücksichtigt.
Professor Martin Müller
von der Uni Lausanne
befasst sich mit der Nachhaltigkeit
von Grossanlässen.
Was sagt er zu dieser Kalkulation?
STIMMEN UNVERSTÄNDLICH - MUSIK
Dank Kompensationen
zur Klimaneutralität.
Und das, obwohl die Emissionen für eine WM
noch nie so hoch waren wie in Katar.
3,6 Millionen Tonnen CO2.
Und das konservativ gerechnet.
Das ist fast so viel wie die Schweiz
in einem ganzen Jahr ausstösst.
Eines der Hauptprobleme
ist der Austragungsort an sich.
Der zweite grosse Kritikpunkt:
Die Baustellen der Stadien,
die ab 2014 gebaut werden.
Es geht um Sicherheitsmängel,
Todesfälle
und menschenunwürdige Zustände
in den Unterkünften.
Menschenrechtsorganisationen berichten
von Zwangsarbeit und Ausbeutung.
Immerhin: Die internationale Kritik
hat gewirkt, wenn auch langsam.
Die Fifa erlässt eine Menschenrechts-Policy.
Auf den Baustellen werden die
Schutzvorschriften angepasst.
Katar reformiert sein Arbeitsrecht
und führt einen Mindestlohn
für Arbeitsmigranten ein,
als erstes Land in der Region.
Sogar das sogenannte Kafala-System
wird 2020 offiziell abgeschafft,
ein System, in dem Arbeitnehmende
fast Leibeigene der Arbeitgeber sind.
Massnahmen also,
um die Situation zu verbessern
und sich natürlich auch
in ein besseres Licht zu rücken.
Aber hat sich auf Stadion-Baustellen
jetzt wirklich etwas verändert?
Wir treffen jetzt Robert Schwitter.
Er war über 40 Jahre lang Bauinspektor
und hat unter anderem in Katar
die Stadionbaustellen inspiziert.
Er ist darum der Richtige,
um mir etwas über die
dortigen Bedingungen zu sagen.
Wir treffen Robert
Schwitter in seinem Revier.
Auf einer Baustelle
ausserhalb von Zürich.
- Dann noch Gilet und Helm, oder?
- Richtig.
Das ist aber ein grosses 39,
das ich hier erwischt habe.
Ab 2017 war er als Teil einer internationalen
Inspektoren-Gruppe mehrmals in Katar.
Wenn Sie jetzt diese Baustelle sehen
und mit Katar vergleichen,
was fällt Ihnen auf?
Klein! Und die Arbeiter
sind warm angezogen.
in Katar ist es natürlich wärmer.
Aber sonst: fast gleich.
Ich war auch überrascht
von der Ordnung auf der Baustelle.
Gehen wir da rein?
Dann sind wir in der Baustelle drin.
Sie haben gesagt,
Sie waren überrascht,
als Sie das erste Mal in Katar
auf einer Baustelle waren.
- Positiv überrascht.
- Positiv überrascht?
Ja. Alle hatten saubere Überkleider,
alle hatten Helme und
Sicherheitsschuhe.
Es gab ein Abfall-Trennsystem,
überall standen Toiletten
und Wasserbehälter.
Im Fernsehen hatte
man ganz andere Sachen gesehen.
Aber Ihre Inspektionen waren
ja immer angekündigt.
- Die Leute wussten, dass Sie kommen.
- Richtig.
Hatten Sie nie den Eindruck,
das sei alles hergerichtet worden?
Das kann man nicht.
Die Erfahrung zeigt mir:
Die müssen das leben.
Das nur schnell herrichten,
das geht nicht.
Das würde man sofort sehen,
wenn es nur geschauspielert ist.
- Man konnte Sie also nicht täuschen?
- Nein, ganz sicher nicht.
Sie waren also auf den Baustellen.
- Waren Sie auch beim Mittagessen dabei?
- Ja.
- Waren Sie in den Unterkünften?
- Auch.
- Und was war Ihr Eindruck?
- Das Essen war in meinen Augen sehr gut.
Es war vielfältig.
Weil es verschiedene Kulturen hatte,
gab es auch
verschiedene Küchen.
Für Inder gab es etwas Spezielles,
für Pakistani, für Veganer ...
Bei den Unterkünften gab es je nach
Qualifikation und Ranghöhe
Viererzimmer oder Zweierzimmer
und auch Einzelzimmer.
Die Duschen wurden
regelmässig gereinigt.
Man kann sagen: Es ist fast wie
auf den Schweizer Grossbaustellen.
Diese Inspektionen
konnten erst ab 2017 stattfinden.
Da könnte man ja sagen:
Es wurde alles in Ordnung gebracht,
bevor man Sie auf die Baustellen liess.
- Das ist möglich, ja.
- Ja?
Das ist gut möglich.
Ich bin sehr beeindruckt. Herr Schwitter
hat ein sehr positives Bild gezeichnet
von der Situation auf
den Stadionbaustellen in Katar.
Aber ich frage mich: Wie ist es
auf anderen Baustellen in Katar?
Wie geht es den
anderen Arbeitsmigranten?
Vor allem: Wie nachhaltig
sind die ganzen Verbesserungen?
Antworten darauf
kann Rita Schiavi geben.
Auch sie war mehrmals in Katar.
Als Delegierte der Unia hat sie sich
in einem internationalen Gewerkschaftsbund
für die Rechte der Arbeiter eingesetzt.
- So, hört man es?
- Bestens.
Ich würde jetzt mal böse sagen:
Als wir mit den Inspektionen begannen,
waren die meisten Sachen bereits gut.
Sie hatten bereits vorher
mit Verbesserungen begonnen.
- Sie hatten ja schon 7 Jahre Zeit.
- Genau, ja.
Wobei, gebaut wurde ab 2014/2015.
Was genau konnten Sie mit Ihren
Gewerkschaften in Katar erreichen?
Wir konnten auf
den Stadion-Baustellen ...
Und ich lege Wert darauf: Wir haben nur
die Stadionbaustellen inspiziert.
Das waren etwa 40'000 Arbeiter,
aber es gibt noch etwa eine Million
sonstige Bauarbeiter in Katar.
Für diese 40'000 konnten wir
sehr viel erreichen.
Glauben Sie, diese Standards
werden irgendwann
für alle katarischen Baustellen gelten?
Wir möchten das natürlich.
Und es hat effektiv
schon eine Ausstrahlung
über die Stadionbaustellen hinaus.
Denn die Firmen, die Stadien
und auch anderes bauen,
wenden die gleichen Standards an,
auch bei anderen Bauten.
Wir denken, dass es bereits gewirkt hat
über die Stadionbaustellen hinaus.
Aber es muss noch weitergehen.
Viele Baustellen haben
längst nicht diese Standards.
Fürchten Sie, dass man wieder nachlässig wird,
wenn die WM einmal vorbei ist?
Vor allem betreffend die Umsetzung
der neuen Arbeitsrechte?
Klar haben wir diese Angst.
Sie ist wohl auch berechtigt.
Im Moment geht es uns vor um eines.
Man muss sehen: Sie haben jetzt
das Arbeitsrecht positiv angepasst,
aber es ist noch nicht überall implementiert.
Da wollen wir noch eine Rolle spielen.
Wir wollen wirklich schauen,
dass die Umsetzung überall garantiert ist.
Dass die Leute diese Rechte überall
bekommen und einfordern können.
- Gut. Es ist kalt, nicht wahr?
- Ja, genau.
Was Frau Schiavi erzählt,
bestätigt auch Amnesty International.
Dank internationalem Druck
habe sich sehr viel verändert,
besonders auf den Stadionbaustellen.
Die Situation sei für den grössten Teil
der Gastarbeitenden
aber immer noch schwierig,
weil die Reformen nur
ungenügend umgesetzt würden.
Bleibt die Frage:
Was passiert nach der WM
mit diesen ganzen Verbesserungen?
Wie holt sich ein Wüstenstaat
ohne Fussballtradition eine WM?
Katar hat es vorgemacht.
Mit einer Sportoffensive,
dank korrupten Fifa-Mitgliedern,
einer umstrittenen Abstimmung
und schliesslich mithilfe einer geschickten,
wenn auch nur teils erfolgreichen, Imagekampagne.
MUSIK
Yacine, was bleibt?
Die Weltmeisterschaft steht kurz bevor.
Das finde ich genau spannend:
Das Spiel ist so viel stärker
als jegliche Moral und Ethik.
Es ist nicht einfach,
ein finales Urteil zu fällen.
Es ist nicht nur gut oder nur schlecht.
Ich möchte festhalten,
dass es auch für uns wahnsinnig schwierig ist.
Wir hoffen, dass wir wenigstens mit diesem Film
ein differenziertes Bild zeigen konnten.
Was meinst du dazu?
Schreibe uns deine Gedanken,
deine Meinung deine
Fragen in die Kommentare.